all right you guys ready for a road trip
too bad we're going anyways
well guys welcome to emerald isle north
carolina the southern portion of the
outer banks me and the family we're
gonna be here for about a week you guys
excited yeah
[Applause]
well becca's parents drove down and
joined us for the week and uh we're
gonna go with them and do a little walk
on the beach here
nathan no nathan
nathan come here told him not to get wet
less than five minutes they got wet all
right come on boys
yeah i think we got enough food
that's a good looking plane right there
look at that well i better get these
kids to bed because we got to get up
super early tomorrow we're going fishing
i'll see you guys then
[Music]
you can't pull up your pants
well good morning good morning good
doing well good to see you guys
all right guys we're back with tombstone
charters and captain jared me and tommy
went with him and had a bang-up time uh
earlier this year so we're back at it
again and we're going to go try to catch
anything that bites
we've been jogging for about an hour
here in a beautiful little spot out in
the middle of the ocean we're just slow
trolling for king mackerel here and this
time of year they tend to be in schools
so if we hit one there's a real good
chance we're gonna hit a couple of them
you're gonna barf do it on camera you
gotta be like aunt melanie and say click
subscribe after you throw up
[Music]
you do look like you're doing a little
better date
right
you want to hold it or you want to put
in the rod holder nate oh that's a real
fish bud
you got it
alma cos yeah yeah those are good
look at that
you feel better buddy yeah yeah it's
hard to tell the difference between an
albico jack and a small amberjack
the key is right there
right there that little bone right there
if it's flat and straight across it's an
almaco jack if it curls up flips up it's
an amberjack
i'm busting out my uh catfish and carp
signature series rods here and we're
gonna try jigging for some amberjack
with them
right here that's a lizard fish look at
the teeth on him
there we go tommy's been out cold for a
while as soon as i pick up a lizard fish
he just bolts up and goes listen fish as
much as i hate to give up our secret
awesome lizard fish spot we are gonna go
try for something else here we're gonna
move spot
we're gonna see what we can do here
oh there we go
[Music]
keep you from going in
oh i'm working you now sucker
nice that's a nice ramiko
look at that that is a beautiful almaco
jack
probably is shark i have experience the
world's smallest
vermilion snapper two of them two that's
a double toby yeah let's see what we got
cigar metal i think it's like look at
that i'd eat that if i was an amberjack
yeah let's go dude
let's do it all right guys we moved
spots and we're going to try something a
little different we're going to bottom
fish with some bait we got little chunks
of false albacore tuna here got little
hi-low rigs
little double rig number snappers
groupers i mean everything loves to eat
these little chunks of meat
all right tom come here bud
oh i got one too
come here nate come on we're not here 30
seconds we got a double what you got
a big bass oh that's pretty cool i think
that's that's your biggest bank bass
oh you already got a little black bass
baby yeah yeah they've got to be 13
inches
oh yeah
i'm hoping
oh you've
oh look he's angry he's look at those
angry eyes how do you say hello daddy
we got boys cranking to the left of me
we got boys cranking to the right of me
look at that
keep working them tom i think you got a
good one too here
oh yeah another double double
you give it a jerk we kind of leave it
there oh no yeah
there he is yeah you got it
all right tom look at that oh
yes
there he is
[Music]
dude they're huge
see the size of them look at the teeth
marks on that one though
that looks like grouper marks on that on
that other one though that did
look at that right there oh yeah
yeah right there yeah yes beers have a
big those are big bee liners
i think we got a grouper down there
though
my rod
all right guys check out the new
sawed-off version of the catfishing cart
special
it's pretty much the same rod with a
shorter handle for those who like uh
kind of more like a one-handed number
yeah it comes with a detachable fish
bonker
is
get some of that
that's a gag grouper right
creeper
that's oh yeah look at the baby remote
oh the little why'd you pick him up put
him back in the water i always wanted to
touch your remora oh
there we go that's my first grouper what
a way to start man i jumped in the deep
end of the pool
what a fish look at the teeth on him
look at those fangs
oh yes we can
we've got a lot of pretty crazy fish on
these catfishing carp rods i've been
wondering for over the year what it
would take to break one so now we know
two big uh b-liners and uh like a big
grouper
[Music]
look at that one man
beautiful sniper yeah you get two of
them on there they definitely gonna pull
like that
that's a nice one
okay
there you go davey got one
holy mad mackerel look at this bucket of
fish oh my snapper holy snapper keep
going
don't stop till you get enough or just
pull them in the boat once you hold them
in the boat
look i can see him i can see him
oh that was a bad one
look at the muscle on that guy oh
oh
he's got one
got one
oh no dad tommy that's a nice one here
here oh
check it
beautiful
these
out
double bees
all right we're going to probably hold
on to this one yeah i think we might
need to do an inventory of them
okay
one three three four five
seven eight nine
18 19.
do i have any fishermen here that can
help us catch our last vermilion
snappers
thank you thank you young man yes yes
sir
well we're going to drift back over that
spot and get another piece of that
action tom's ripping in the snapper
would you catch tom
oh that's a pretty fish look at that
thing
that looks like a group to me
oh there's an enormous sea turtle right
there
oh look at the size of that guy nathan
you can surf on that guy it's in color
what is it oh
oh look at that
do you know what that is nathan
a shark just bit your fish in half sure
did look at that
he's still alive that's white bow and
porgy yeah he has been half deboned
nathan you had a shark on oh no
okay this one
that is a beefcake
david baby come on there you go
nice grouper bait right there
oh look at this
i also think that looks like grouper
got a beehive
oh i saw a shark you saw a shark
american red snapper american red sniper
all right he's out of season so he's
going back yep little guy and what is
this thing that is a a grunt or tom tape
tom tape yeah it's a grunt that's
looks like a nice b liner and a bake
bass it's been a good day when you're
releasing your biggest yes it is
good problem oh look at this double
double b's
oh turn them loose yeah we got so much
and david's got some more on over there
this is like our 50th vermilion snapper
or something out here what is it
oh look at this passes we can do it
what you got oh you got a vermillion
snapper there got plenty of those holy
values
oh
is that even bigger than dad's that is a
great jack
look at that
look at that i think that one might even
be bigger than dad's mind that's
something yeah it's bigger than yourself
[Music]
look at that american red look at those
tom that's your first american red
snapper that's big
yeah that's a nice fish
yeah you can see they got a little nice
snapper right there nice red american
red snapper
yeah
[Music]
yeah you are the alphago jack king nice
was that fun
yeah did we catch like a bazillion fish
yes i have no idea how many fish we
caught and i didn't film all of them
there was a lot of them that just got in
and out before i could get the camera
over well you think we're gonna eat good
fish yeah yeah yeah we're gonna probably
gonna both after i eat all that yeah i'm
gonna barf after you eat all those fish
yeah because we're stuffed so full
the fish yeah i think we got more than
one meals worth well we gotta go take
these back to shore clean them up and uh
we're gonna do some cooking it's gonna
be good all right guys you ready to head
back
you want me to join you
all right i'm coming
ah
oh that is comfy
oh yeah
a
lot
look at this pile of fish holy mackerel
37 pounds minus two pounds for the
basket so that's 35.
pounds that is
that's a lot of little bass and snapper
that's great
caught these hands over fist and
caught some jacks on light tackle
yeah it's good times
all right guys every time i see one of
these guys cleaning fish you always look
at their fillet knives there's a million
different types of fillet knives on the
market but everybody who does this a lot
uses the dexter russells occasionally
they'll go with the bubba knives
it's like you've done this before
couple times
they're delicious
1743 ounces
that's right
i'm paying a good pace for that at the
market too yes yeah
12.4 12.4
grand total 73 pounds of fish not too
shabby
all right guys we're back at the house
and uh we're gonna cook up some of that
fish
i'm feeling like fish tacos
[Music]
[Music]
big piece of gag grouper right there
[Music]
[Music]
little jalapeno cilantro sauce avocado
little bingo salsa not too shabby
tommy and nathan are both citing
injuries and medical issues to avoid
eating it though so hit him
no i can't see i got sunscreen in my
mouth so you want some fish tacos i can
put it in your mouth for you
well it's another early morning and me
and jacob are going fishing
for back here with tombstone's charters
and we're going to go for another day
here this time we let little jacob have
a go at it he cried a little bit when
nate and tom got to go fishing and he
got left behind but not today huh yeah
yeah you excited to catch some fish
we're just cruising along to see a bunch
of
right
porpoises
wow
that was way cool get a fishing trip and
a free whale watching tour all in one
we're gonna drop down one of the little
snapper rigs see what jacob can catch
and uh
anything little we're gonna put on a
grouper rig drop down and try to catch
another grouper maybe a shark
amberjack who knows all righty
look
[Music]
jacob look you caught that good job
buddy
you need help okay
oh
that is a nice vermilion snapper look at
that big guy
there you go
jake's a little like his brothers he
gets a little pale when the boat starts
moving so
he's tired we're gonna put him on the
bean bag let him rest a little bit
oh yeah those triggers are good eating
fish there we go nice b-liner yep white
boat porgy that's the same fish nathan
cops got bit in half by this jar yeah
yeah very goody
he munched my fish that's a decent one
look at this we are off to a roaring
start oh that is a chunky guy look at
here tearing up the black bass
another nice trigger fish
we are doing good in the bait department
yeah
oh jake's taking it easy
my live bait ain't still alive anymore
he had his face bitten off boy caught a
lot of black bass and trigger fish and
some vermillion snapper not a bad spot
at all but it's cooling off a little bit
so we're gonna go try another spot
oh
what's the garbage i think
he is smaller than my lure
oh that cigar minnow didn't last long oh
it's a grouper
a little undersized
now pretty thing
that feels good
another big one look at that sucker
beautiful fish
well that was good we're gonna go try
another spot
got it
slab snapper right there
oh yeah that's the keeper
right there it just doesn't take long
i mean you're just getting hits
within five seconds of being on the
bottom or you're doing something wrong
nice color oh there we go
snapper so pretty
hi buddy
hell is that a crazy looking heel yeah
yeah they got teeth with teeth inside of
teeth oh yeah
there you go
yeah you like that
big old vermilion snapper
oh
that cool
you want to catch one or you just want
to watch
well yeah you're gonna get to watch as
much as you want
massive chunk of albacore
[Music]
look at that guy
that is a big boy that's a basket of
fish isn't it jake
[Music]
that's so amazing
all right another gorgeous spot we're
going to see what we can catch
oh look at this
ringtail borgie
they are yummy but he's too little
oh oh
you got the group for that
oh look at that there's a grouper
look at that
another gag grouper
another grouper
look at this number six
well guys it has been an awesome day
but i think it's time to get back to
shore
we have tore up the fish again hey jake
do you have a good time
yeah yeah good time good all right glad
you came
[Music]
look at him beautiful fish
look at that that is a pile of fish
right there
six pounds six pounds get out these are
the trigger fish i've had more than one
person tell me that this is their
favorite fish to eat around here a lot
of people like them don't they they do
they do excellent meat
a lot of people describe them as
scallops it's kind of like a scallop
firm meat kind of a sweet white meat
we're keeping some of these carcasses
for shark fishing later
you were right 12 pounds
jared man we had such a good time thank
you again if you guys are ever down at
atlantic beach north carolina and you
want to do this check out tombstone
charters and i'll put a link down in the
video description below
it's awesome man i can't wait to do it
again right on yes sir me too well that
was pretty awesome
oh i'm so tired but i've got a nice
grouper taco here
i got my lovely wife and all of this
here is my
scenery hopefully just sitting here
enjoying the view a little bit will give
me some energy
well we've only got one hour before the
sun sets and uh me and jake decided that
we are going to go surf fishing don't
know if we'll catch anything
but it's too gorgeous not to try
look at that
just a wonderful wonderful beautiful day
i'm getting to hang out with my boy
yeah
all right tom really and see if we got a
little fish on there you got two
zombie you have a double
there we go
elise you want to do the release all
right i want to do the release here
here
all right
drop them
yeah
oh look at that there we go another
little one
yeah hold on grab it grab it tub grab it
it's it's a shark
it's a shark
hold on here we go real real tom i can't
i gotta hold on to this rod or i'm gonna
lose my rod oh this is a strong shark
hold it hold it tight dog
whoa a little ways off but we should see
him soon get up get him on top don't let
it go down
whoa
pull it off pull it up
oh he's big tom
oh that's a big stingray tom
scared watch out for the stink that's
the barb
that's the size look at the size of this
bar oh okay step on his tail
oh all right he's unhooked
day one
that is like a 30 pound stingray it is
huge
there he goes
tommy
was that cool yes i got i won because i
got more fish than you oh you sure did
i thought it was like josh it's pretty
late and i'm not sure how we're gonna
top that so we're gonna pack it up go
home we got a lot of fishing to do
tomorrow
it is a beautiful low-key day-to-day
getting the kids dressed got them fed
we're going to do some sightseeing stuff
here in the morning and in the afternoon
we've got some pretty exciting fishing
we're going to do
soon
[Music]
all right out of the car you maniacs
welcome to fort macon this is near where
blackbeard the pirate crashed his ship
oh look at this
yeah
look at this these are all the different
shells on the beach and surf has been
popular ever since it's a microscope
tommy look it's my finger look at the
boogers under that fingernail here let's
look at daddy's gross fingernails oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is an yeah for making hot shot you
would heat up the cannonballs red hot
and then shoot them at chips and light
them on fire
[Music]
god
[Applause]
well we're back at the house and we're
hungry so we're gonna make some fish
sandwiches we got some crispy louisiana
fish fries got some vermilion snapper
and some trigger fish fillets oh you
reach over and grab them
[Music]
what do you think babe it's really
really good
there you go
well now that lunch is over we're going
to do some serious fishing
right out there
here's my fishing let i made it in a
cupcake tin it's about two pounds of
lead and a little bit of coat hanger
there we go got a nice little hook big
rod big hooks big bait
got that hooked up
all right so here's the plan i'm gonna
take that kayak put my lead and bait on
it and i'm gonna kayak way out there
drop my bait in the ocean kayak back and
get the next one
i'm gonna get a little wet
i'm on raw duty looks like it's maybe
getting close to halfway
that's cold
now we wait for either a shark or
hypothermia to come well i got tommy to
come out and join us if i promised him
i'd keep him warm
[Applause]
yeah promise is a promise gotta keep the
boy happy i also promised him that let
him reel in any of the fish on the big
surf rods on the left get it get get it
get it get it
tommy saw a bunch of fish swimming right
in the waves as they're cresting on the
shore and so it went and threw it right
into the breakers it gave off he came up
we'll get another one there was tons of
them
that's a florida pompano
that's cool when they're bigger they're
good to eat
another florida pompano look at that
bend in the rock
all right let's see what it is there we
go got a little double two king fish
look really it is look at this right
there that's the biggest king fish so
far man
good job let's get him let's get him
back in the water i see him we got one
another little kingfish
look at this oh another sandy little
kingfish
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
200 pound steel leader connected to that
and it broke well guys we've caught
about eight kingfish to pompano and lost
one shark but a good time nonetheless
and uh i got a sneaky feeling this isn't
our last time shark fishing on this trip
we're gonna get one but i got kids to
get to bed and i'll see you guys in the
morning
good morning it's another beautiful day
and we have got a lot more adventure
planned today we're gonna do some
fishing of course and we're going to go
see pirate ships are you guys ready to
see pirate ships yeah yeah come on guys
to the car to the car all right guys so
apparently blackbeard the pirates ship
the queen anne's revenge was wrecked
near here and they have a bunch of the
artifacts from his pirate ship at the
north carolina maritime museum so we're
gonna go check out blackbeard the
pirates ship
all right everybody out as slowly and
disorderly as possible
it's a clam rake oh it's eel trap see
the eel inside the eel trap
yeah it's a whale's heart cut in half
isn't that cool and here's all the
different parts of the heart it's a lead
pipe that goes from the toilet into the
ocean so it's it's the poop hole you
look at the sword right
is yeah queen anne's revenge it's all
stuff from the pirate ship yeah these
are all from the sea oh look those are
bullets yeah oh those are plates
[Music]
a pirate hook and a pirate eye patch all
right my scurvy sea dogs did you have a
good time
right guys we're back at the house and
we're going to cook up some more of that
fish i'm going to do a parmesan
encrusted baked vermilion snapper with
some sort of lime butter i'm going to
try to recreate a recipe me and becca
had in the florida keys a little while
ago and i'm gonna do some sort of pan
seared grouper i have no idea what i'm
gonna do i'm just gonna
figure it out as i go we got some good
irish butter here oh look at how yellow
that is
[Music]
a little garmin masala on the top salt
pepper very simple very nice
[Music]
all right fantastic all good
we've got four vermilion snapper fillets
we're gonna season with salt and pepper
then we're gonna put them in panko we're
gonna put a little bit of garlic masala
lime zest and parmesan cheese on them
and we're going to bake them
[Music]
all right there we go vermillion snapper
baked in panko parmesan cheese with key
lime butter and a little bit of
scallions and tomatoes
you like that babe was that good very
good oh excellent
come here john come here
aye aye
aye aye boy
that'd be a lot better than
maggot infested
her
cat i'm nice and full i think it's time
for round two of shark fishing
well me and becca had a scuba diving
spearfishing charter planned for
tomorrow but uh looks like the weather's
gonna cancel that
so uh i figured i might as well bust out
my wetsuit since i'm going kayaking out
there won't freeze my butt off as bad
this time
there we go there's another big chunk of
bait shark fishing is a team sport here
and i couldn't do it without my lovely
lovely assistant rebecca
glad you have your wednesday night oh
it's quite pleasant
he made it
halfway out
the wind came offshore pretty
aggressively
you're gone a long time
oh look at that that's a nice one that's
uh that's actually a proper kingfish
a lot bigger than those babies we've
been reeling in
oh
that's a shark jake
well darn it i thought i'd lost my bait
the sharks just grabbed a little bit
right here they didn't really grab much
i think i might need smaller bait
that might be a little bit better
i got changed out of my wetsuit and my
lovely wife has joined us it's cold
oh
oh new species i think that's a little
puppy drum a little black drum
as the weather gets worse the fish get
bigger little king fish
see how my fish my shark goes
[Music]
[Music]
that's a hefty guy
he feels 300
that was an incredible fight took me
over 35 minutes to reel that sucker in i
think that was the biggest sandbar shark
i've ever caught
that thing felt like it was between 250
300 pounds but i'm tired cold wet i'm
gonna reel this other rod get inside
i think i got another shark on here
you know i mean for being a little guy
he's still pretty respectable
there we go
that looks like another sandbar shark
there you go that was a small one but i
mean still he was a good five feet long
he is respectable
big thanks to the support crew
thanks joe thanks becca
well good morning it's 6 a.m and the
weather forecast says it's going to be
about 45 degrees and up to 25 mile per
hour winds so i thought it'd be a good
idea to get my wife up early drag her
out in the cold and take her fishing
yay
to keep our marriage alive i uh got
these adhesive hand warmers here and i'm
gonna cover my wife
all over
in hand warmers
we're in north carolina and it's
breakfast time so i made biscuits and
gravy
[Music]
let's get some gravy
all right guys it is a brisk november
morning and i'm here with nick with
chasing tails and he is going to take us
out
fishing for we're going to go speckled
trout
oh i've never caught a speckled trout
all right becca you ready for the
coldest part of the whole trip
it's gotta get nippy
it feels kind of quite warm all of a
sudden doesn't it
much better
you're warm
okay oh you're okay good so we've got a
live shrimp here
yep tide's coming in right here
so we're just gonna throw it out there
and just let it get on the bottom and
just hold it just waiting for the fish
to roll in with the tide
oh there we go
i feel warmer already
actually it looks kind of like a catfish
it is a catfish or not i'm a catfish
machine i can't turn it off
look at that i swear this looks like a
white catfish the white catfish are
native to the
brackish water tributaries on the east
coast they have heads kind of like a
bull head and the anal fin is shorter
and has fewer rays than a channel
catfish but i'd have to sit down and
actually count the rays to know for sure
i'm gonna just call it a white catfish
because it's too early in the morning to
be counting spines on a fish's butt
[Music]
oh look at that beautiful trout babe is
that right that's a good size yeah it's
just a good solid keeper flies fish
about 16 inch fish
you see they're two things yellow house
he's got
he's got figs
[Music]
there we go fish now look at that
yeah there you go my first speckled
trout
nice lot red nice red drum awesome fish
these things can get crazy big but this
is a nice one
that's your first red fish
yeah we got
real quick but uh we're gonna try to get
some more species
oh wait we need a few of these
nice bend in the rod
oh
that is a nice black drum a nice drum
[Music]
oh a sheep's head
a very tasty fish so that was a little
small probably yeah i eat barnacles and
clams
oysters bye-bye buddy
another lovely black sea bass
pig
oh
a pig fish all right we might keep this
one give us a try
oh
you're getting lots of chunky black sea
bass
you're the queen of the black sea bass
the big fish oink oink little pig fish
make a little oinky
look at noise beautiful flounder it's uh
that's a summer that's a summer flower
oh we got mr ugly oh look at this little
turtle fish oyster turd oyster toad quit
biting my fire
look at this
and even smaller black bass look at
their jaw right here they can make it
flare blue right there then you kind of
look at that you kind of turn it in the
light
that is so pretty
sweet
oh
black bass
look at that a lovely flounder
well guys this has been an awesome day i
have lost count of how many fish we
caught i think we got nine different
species of fish and best of all i gotta
do it with my wife here in the boat
love you babe we threw back most our
fish but we kept a couple of those
speckled trout and that hog fish so uh
we gotta go clean up our fish and we got
some more cooking to do
you have fun babe i had a good time
i'm much warmer now it helps
i lost count of how many fish we caught
i mean
i think we got a lot
electric powered scale
holy mackerel
yeah somebody gave me that and
i've been thanking them ever since
oh man
yeah
well nick thank you very much thank you
oh it does
listen if you guys are down here and you
want to catch a bunch of these inshore
fish come here to chase and tails ask
for nick and he'll take you out there
i'll make sure to put a link down in the
video description to the website contact
info
all right thank you guys thank you again
thank you enjoyed it
feels good to have the heat on doesn't
it babe it's really good i'm very hungry
you want some donuts yeah all right
let's get donuts
all right guys we're at the flip-flop
donut shop here and uh we are about to
increase our caloric intake for the
day oh my goodness
this is so naughty
should i wait for everybody or should i
eat one eat one
smells good this might be the apple
cider one hey boys
hey we like donuts all right go for it
what do you think by popular request i'm
going to fry up some grouper and we're
going to do some fish and chips
yeah
there you go thank you
yeah grouper fish and chips
got some of this sweet chili sauce and
mayo mix that's gonna be what we dip our
fries and uh fish in
not traditional but
hey tom where are we headed we're
heading to a fishing pier
and as you can see tom is really leaning
into the pirate theme here at the outer
banks
are
if you're new to fishing saltwater you
might want to check out these fishing
piers we're here at the bogue inlet
fishing pier and uh we're gonna see if
we can't catch something
yeah that'd be great
nice thing about learning how to fish on
a fishing pier is they've got a tackle
shop right at the end of the pier so you
can get everything you need and you got
lots of people around so you can see
what other people are doing what's
biting and you can learn really quick
one thing you learn really quick about
fishing piers is how far out you go
affects what kind of fish you catch
so you can catch certain types of fish
right in the surf in the swells some you
catch over the sand bars some you catch
among the pilings others want deep open
water as you walk down the pier you'll
notice that people are fishing for
different types of things and reeling in
different types of fish
there we go tom
oh
that's actually it's toasty here yeah
you got a little hot chocolate got a
spot out of the wind this might be okay
little spot kingfish rig
okay
put it over the edge
and you just drop it down straight down
that right there is a pin fish
there we go that's a pinfish a really
popular bait fish that's about as big as
they get they love to steal bait you're
free
there he goes
he fights it
look at that
look at that giant ray down there
oh look at that he's coming right for us
oh
oh
yeah yeah let's hit the line pull them
up see what we got
oh
look at this that that right there is a
citation pinfish
there you go
how you doing are you cold yes do you
want to go in yes oh [ __ ]
well did you have a blast tommy yeah i
have a blast me time
you know we're gonna do a little more
sightseeing and keeping with the whole
fish theme of this trip we're going to
the aquarium
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
guys did you have fun at the aquarium
yeah yeah now would you like to go in
the hurricane simulator
that's like the weakest hurricane ever
that was only 78 miles per hour all
right guys to the car
you guys have a good time yeah
[Music]
all right you ready for a five hour
drive back home
no
travel montage activate
[Music]
well guys we made it back home and we
had a wonderful trip full of wonderful
food we hope you guys enjoyed coming
along for the ride if you want to see
more travel and adventure videos check
out our travel and adventure playlist if
you want to see more catch and cook
videos check out our catch and cook
video playlist thanks for watching guys
make sure to click subscribe we put out
new videos every saturday morning if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor boys youtube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching